6500 personnes selon la police voilà le
nombre de carnavaliers qui ont décidé de
se déguiser pour défilé dimanche dans le
centre ville de marseille
alors que l'épidémie liée à la copie 19
fait rage dans toute la france un
événement qui n'était bien entendu pas
autorisé auquel se sont prêtés des
milliers de marseillais déguisés pour la
plupart son masque et bien sûr son
respect des gestes barrières sur les
images on se croirait revenu en 2019 sur
bfm télé la porte parole du ministère de
l'intérieur s'est indigné d'un tel
comportement
c'est irrespectueux de tous les gens qui
font des efforts et c'est inacceptable
même son cloche du côté de la mairie de
marseille avec yannick ohanessian ce qui
s'est passé hier est évidemment
inexcusable un défilé sauvage qui était
aussi et surtout un pied de nez aux
autorités pour exprimer un ras-le-bol
des mesures sanitaires
neuf personnes ont été interpellées
alors les organisateurs du carnaval à
marseille doivent-ils être condamné
alors ça ça fait énormément parler en ce
week-end de richard merci d'être là
participant au carnaval
pourquoi vous avez aucun laval vous vous
en aviez marre vous vouliez voilà mais
comme je vais tous les ans au carnaval
donc enfin sauf l'année dernière mais ça
quand je vais au carnaval est l'un des
premiers participants au carnaval de la
plaine mais non non d'accord et et n'ai
pas eu peur n'est pas une obsession
vous dites pas ces noms vous avez envie
voilà d'y aller parce que voilà c'était
ça vous fait pas ça vous remonter le
moral vous avez envie d'être avec des
gens où ils avaient envie tu es ce que
je fais d'habitude et je vois mais je ne
change pas les habitudes comme ça c'est
pas est-ce que vous avez vous conscience
que ça pouvait être dangereux ou pas du
tout non pour vous est peut-être pour
aider si c'était dangereux je ne sera
pas d'accord aujourd'hui ce que vous
avez peur peut-être d'avoir été
contaminées ou non ne savent pas du tout
pas du tout pas du tout vous vouliez
gagner parce que si demain les les
chiffres de la coved augmente à
marseille à cause de ce cadre elle est
où vous allez vous sentir coupable ou es
ce que vous avez vous dire non j'ai fait
écouter
roselyne bachelot avait proposé de faire
des concerts test alors c'est peut être
qu'il y en aura peut-être que y en aura
pas en tout cas donc là on était six
mille cinq cent suivant la police alors
dix mille suivant les organisateurs
d'accord donc du coup moi ce que j'ai
dit à tous les
ja ce que tous les manifestants qui
étaient présents là si jamais ils sont
malades qui se signalent
et comme ça on sera si effectivement le
virus a circulé mois si jamais je tombe
malade je dirais je anglade et vous êtes
tous pour les sanctionner ladjimi
l'argumentaire est complètement
catastrophique de dire quoi faire un
test grandeur nature je rappelle que les
gens qui meurent de ce genre de test
hasardeuse que vous proposez une chose
est claire c'est que le problème
actuellement c'est la vaccination c'est
pas le carnaval en vrai si on veut
présenter les vrai problème en france
c'est l'accident qui n'a pas été vite et
on en train de faire un tri a jugé
l'accord supportable on vaccine les plus
de 75 ans est en dessous de 75 ans il
faut avoir des pathologies extrêmement
grave
un cancer ne suffit pas il faut avoir un
cancer non une chimiothérapie dans donc
c'est ça le mollet en france c'est qu'on
va pas assez vite et qu'on n'ouvre pas
la vaccination et qu'on ne propose pas
correctement un vaccin ont un coût on
met astrazeneca c'est jacques a dit je
mets astradec à jacques a dit je ne mets
pas 65 ans 55 ans c'est confus en
revanche je comprends que vous en avez
marre
moi aussi j'en ai marre les étudiants en
ont marre dans les ehpad ils ont marre
les restaurateurs on en a on l'a tous
marre et on n'interdit pas les gens de
sortir dehors sortez dehors probablement
qu'à moins de risques durant le carnaval
que dans certaines écoles c'est vrai
qu'on parle les écoles de façon un peu
obscure on a l'impression qu'ils s'y
passe rien pour autant on le sait c'est
un moteur de l'épidémie mais il faut
laisser les écoles ouvertes
en revanche ce qu'on vous demande c'est
un minimum de cohérence si vous êtes
dehors porter un masque
c'est pas grand chose qu'on vous demande
un minimum de distance mois quand j'en
ai marre bah je vais avec mes enfants je
vais dans un parc
je reste loin des gens j'apporte un
masque je limite le risque en revanche
quand on voit les images actuellement
merzhin à quoi ils jouent
est ce que vraiment vous respectez les
soignants qui à quelques kilomètres de
là ce monde et services de réanimation
galère depuis un an
ils ont non pas avec des gens qui
meurent tous les jours est ce que vous
pensez leur faire honneur
alors qu'on vous demande pas grand-chose
respecter des gestes-barrières mettre un
masque et temporiser est-ce que les
soigneurs pas il ya des gens qui font
des manifestations toutes les semaines à
paris faudrait aussi les interdire si on
pensait que c'était risqué mais on vous
demande un masque à peu de distance
en revanche chanter crier danser et
collés les uns sur les autres je pense
que malheureusement cette image n'est
pas acceptable
aucun char est ce que les soignants été
respectée avant le coup vide
est-ce qu'ils n'étaient pas déjà
surchargés de travail est la seule à le
retaper pas dessus parce que ils
réclament effectivement des moyens
supplémentaires
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit qu'ils en ont
besoin aujourd'hui ils deviennent des
héros
il ya un an peut-être que vous étiez
parmi les manifestants qui réclamaient
un peu plus de
de moyens pour soigner les gens
aujourd'hui on a notre système de santé
n'est pas adaptée ni aux kovy denis à ce
qui se passait à part vous avez quel âge
unique 54 ans vous êtes à risque de
formes graves de coronavirus et c'est
aussi en partie pour vous qu'on s'est
arrêté de vivre en quelque sorte les
plus jeunes se sont arrêtés de vivre
pour protéger les plats alors on ne le
fait pas si c'est pour moi non savard
énorme et c'est pas ces principes de
solidarité donc le minimum qu'on demande
aux gens c'est un peu de bon sens et
sortez dehors c'est possible mais le
masque et la distance s'était pas trop
demander s'il y en a que deux qui disent
non au gabon les organisatrices
d'ailleurs c'est kelly et guillaume
blais les deux plus jeunes
kelly pourquoi ben moi je peux
comprendre qu'il ya des personnes que
c'est soit ça soit le fichier dont va
être clair on a beaucoup dit suisse il
en a beaucoup qui déprime
donc à un moment donné quand tu laisses
les métros ouvert quand on laisse les
écoles ouvertes quand une lettre et
chose car il ya des gens qui n'arrivent
pas à comprendre et je peux le
comprendre qu'ils aient envie à un
moment donné de péter les plombs et
d'être dehors après moi je fais
confiance aux personnes qui le font si
tu vas ce truc là tu prends ton risque
et après tu t'isoles et tu vas pas
contaminer les autres moi j'ai envie
d'être naïve et de croire à ça c'est
chacun est maître de son jeu si vous
voulez allez vous contaminer vous faites
mais vous respectez les gens je l'espère
guillaume à la vraie question c'est
pourquoi les gens ont fait ça les gens
ont fait ça parce qu'ils n'en peuvent
plus parce que ça fait un an qu'ils
n'ont pas eu d'interaction sociale etc
c'est tout simplement inhumain ne pas
avoir d'interactions sociales pendant un
an ils n'ont pas de perspective
si encore on aussi encore on leur disait
les gars dans un mois si vous êtes libre
mais non c'est pas donc c'est bon la
police du coup vide là oui allez vous
devriez faire si vous devez porter votre
masse vous n'avez pas honte de sortir
vous n'avez pas honte de ci de ça les
gens ont le droit de vivre ça va durer
combien de temps d'avoir une division
vous enfoncerez sont rien de ce carnaval
répondre à la question il me posait pas
une autre question
problème votre camp son repas dans les
livres c'est c'est relativement simple
pour le juriste en tout cas si le port
du masque est obligatoire à l'extérieur
bah là c'est le jury ce qui par bah oui
mais c'est la casquette d'avocat oui
mais je peux donner autrement quand je
suis fier parce que la question de la
contamination à l'extérieur et ses
terrasses et toujours on va toujours
avoir un débat sur ce point et donc la
question c'est est ce que moi j'ai
attaqué le port du masque à l'extérieur
est ce que vous pensez que vous pensez
qu'ils doivent être sanctionnés les
organisateurs non voilà moi aussi je
pense qu'il faut laisser passer
non non je pense avoir des manips de
2000 personnes puis trente mille
personnes sans mal
et là où je suis surpris monsieur chaud
je vous trouve deux fois égoïste d'avoir
déjà participé à ça et puis surtout de
venir sur le plateau sans masque moi
vous avez communauté avec 6500 personnes
en train de danser ou 17 ans quand j'en
ai rien à faire machin mais c'est assez
égoïste de votre part de vous trimballez
comme ça sans masque voilà jouer ou non
je crains malpas en basse que là tout le
monde et sans masque alors mais c'est
pas droit la production m'a bien sûr ils
me considèrent comme du lot
ou alors ce sont des espèces a pris char
c'est quoi la lettre que vous avez là là
c'est juste un petit texte qui
représente un peu l'état d'esprit de du
carnaval alors je suis en aucun cas
porte-parole de quoi que ce soit
je me sens super mal ça serait ma
réponse est je pense que certains amis
sont d'accord mais je suis passé je vais
je suis pas représentative des milliers
de personnes qui étaient là hier et ses
longs cheveux noirs
ça fait longtemps qu'on a pas écrit la
une est comme ça ici non mais alors
résumé c'est quoi en résumé donc je
voulais aller on va pas lire la lettre
on vous imagine cher mais pas tous bons
marseille la rebelle la plaine ton coeur
qui rythment la résistance à avec joie
fêter son carnaval dans la plus grande
tradition populaire seddik témoins des
médias basés note vas-y les bien
pensants montre quatre images de
violence image prise à la fin de ce pas
ce partage d'allégresse où seule
l'intervention des forces de l'ordre des
petits groupes isolés a créé chez
certains des réactions non contenue
non ce n'est pas les poubelles qui ont
été brûlés mais comme tous les ans le
quart en montrant symbole du pouvoir
oui nous étions près de 10000 à festoyer
dans les rues d'ailleurs je propose que
les participants qui tomberaient malades
du cobp id ou qui contaminerait
deschamps qui tomberaient malades
le signal pour enfin avoir un test
grandeur nature de la propagation de ce
virus lors de manifestations non il n'y
avait pas que des jeunes ma vie ni que
des punks à chiens y avait pas que des
anarchistes ni
l'ultra gauche il y avait le peuple
marseillais dans sa diversité
on embrasse simple qu'il y a plus de
deux ans occupé cette place de la plaine
pour éviter que 150 arbres soient
coupées que notre marché soient
supprimées que des millions d'euros soit
dépensé pour gentrifié notre quartier
populaire et là vous messieurs les bien
pensants alors c'est pas nous et n'ont
jamais pensé
d'accord lui vous étiez avec vos caméras
moi j'étais pas là bas j'ai moins de
caméras à la caméra le soir car personne
n'a montré dans les logis j'ai le gign
ni les crs déloger brutalement les
familles occupant la place où étiez vous
quand le mur a été bâti en cercle en la
plus grande place de marseille pour
protéger vos exactions sur cette place
carrément ce mur de la honte qui a coûté
près de 300000 euros
on n'a pas vu au journal de 20 heures
mais on a vu les images de ces immeubles
qui se sont effondrés
quelques jours après à quelques dizaines
de mètres de là qui sont les
irresponsables
le peuple qui clame dans la joie sa
liberté où vous les bien pensants il
dilapide est le fruit de nos labeur à
détruire nos modes de vie allez c'est la
misère sur bataille n'en peut plus et si
on est de l'être humain
oui des gens sont morts sous les
décombres de ces immeubles des gens qui
auraient sûrement fêter avec nous quand
saura bien le reste du peuple
marseillais
le carnaval de 2021 remercie richard
pour l'exercice voilà merci richard
donc voila quoi qu'est-ce qui agite je
trouverais sharks c'est un pamphlet
politique donc c'était une manifestation
politique de convocation moi ça m'a
apporté et je vous le dit les yeux dans
les yeux vous m'avez fait on j'adore
marseille mais là c'est de
l'irresponsabilité de la désobéissance
en ville c'est choquant rohr du peuple
marseillais sans aucune et regarder oui
à 61 % non à 38%
on n'a pas entendu ans oui c'est
scandaleux ce qu'ils ont fait mais ça
n'est que le début les gens vont se
révolter contre le confinement ça fait
un an et ils en ont marre et on vaccine
à la vitesse de l'escargot donc la
population en a marre d'attendre alors
qu'elle n'est pas vacciné division a
raison et jimmy mohamed raison de signes
de signaler qu on vaccine trop lentement
voilà et quand les gens vont finir par
craquer parce qu a pas de perspective en
conclusion vous savez que les gens
jeunes sur le plateau au rythme où on va
il vont être vaccinés en novembre
pendant six mois